what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you guys coming off the tales of
kane the conqueror asked me to make a
video
on immortus and so we're going to do
that we're going to explain immortus
now in order to make this explanation
super simple in terms of how to
understand
immortus we talked in the last video
about kane the conqueror with regards to
the fact that he's constantly moving
around the time stream and has created
all these different alternate versions
of themselves
marvel calls them divergent kings uh
those are guys who are coming from loki
you can call them varian kings if you
want to it's all basically the same
thing just alternate reality versions of
kang himself who at one point actually
formed the council of kings so let's
take loki in the marvel cinematic
universe for a second whenever
marvel cinematic universe movies come
out you go to the movie theater and you
watch those movies right so you know how
loki's timeline plays out up into the
events of loki right that loki appeared
in the marvel cinematic universe in the
early days he fought along thor but you
always knew there was something kind of
off about him he ultimately launches the
attack against the avengers or at least
it leads to the formation of the
avengers in the the original avengers
film you then go into like thor the dark
world you go into thor ragnarok
you go into his death in infinity war
you know the life and times of loki
now let's say that as you're watching
this movie unfold you actually
stop loki dying during the events of
infinity war and instead you ensure he
survives into the events of avengers
in-game that's how immortus works that
immortus is basically
outside of time but can intervene
throughout the time stream
at any point in time and actually change
things and he serves a far more
grandiose purpose
than what kang does we'll make more
sense of that as we go through this but
the origin of immortus is essentially
the exact same as the origin of king of
course he originally appeared and
avengers number 10 back in 1964 with
stan lee and don heck
but while he did appear in avengers 10
it wasn't until we got to avengers
forever that we actually got
a real tried and true origin of a
mortise we got little bits and pieces
along the way but it all sort of came
together in amalgamated in avengers
forever which gave us a more significant
and really full-on depiction of how this
guy works so
to kind of touch on this a little bit
let's talk about what the
the significance of avengers forever was
so let's you guys never saw our video on
king so while this story does split the
comic book community down the middle in
the sense that you'll find marvel comics
fans who detest
this story and then you'll find marvel
comics fans who absolutely love it the
significance of it cannot be overstated
but the whole purpose and really one of
the biggest things about
about avengers forever it gave us this
idea that when it came to the time
keepers that of course the time keepers
and the time twisters were basically the
exact same beings the difference
is that the time twisters decided to
conquer all of reality and the time
keepers wanted to preserve
all of reality and they were two
possible futures and so the time
twisters were always working to make
sure the future whereby they were the
ones who reigned supreme instead of the
time keepers came into existence and the
timekeepers were looking to do the exact
opposite ensure that their future came
into existence which is why the
timekeepers were largely shown to be
selfish in a lot of ways they were
literally just trying to preserve their
own existence
and so when you got to the events of
avengers forever one of the big things
that happened is that one
revealed that kang and ramatat and
immortus were all basically the same
person
and two it revealed that immortus was
the end result of what kang would become
that when you follow this kind of
chronological
timeline that you have rama tut then you
have kang then you have immortis and you
got a few characters in between iron lad
kita mortis people like that but
uh those are kind of like the big three
and that immortus was the person that
kang and rama tut would ultimately end
up becoming
and so the reason why this was
significant is because all their
destinies were basically intertwined
together
it was a guaranteed thing right that
king in his early days
would go into the past he would adopt
the moniker of rama tut he would do some
things and then rama tut would go back
into his timeline so basically the 30th
century and then adopt the moniker of
kang
and then kang would screw up and mess up
the time stream and then at some future
point
immortus would basically come into
existence right we didn't really know
how a mortise came into existence we
just knew that he would
the reason why i talk about avengers
forever here is because what ended up
happening is that during this story when
their destinies were basically
you know ripped away from each other
meaning one was not guaranteed to become
the other
this largely impacted rama tut and what
this ended up doing was it led to rama
tut basically entering the realm of
limbo now that's where things got a
little bit wonky because when you go
into avengers forever issue number nine
one of the things that you learn
is that when ramat had gone to the realm
of limbo and then basically was
designed to achieve immortality and then
ultimately gave himself the name of
immortus that when you're in limbo and
we'll explain more about limbo here in a
second but when you're in limbo you can
see
all these different realities that are
there and you can actually see divergent
realities right so possible alternate
realities that can come into existence
rahmat observing all these looked into
the future and saw that somewhere along
the line that immortus would basically
become an
agent of the time keepers and so
desiring to keep that from happening
rama tut
left limbo or at least a version of him
left limbo and then went back to his
native universe
and became kane the conqueror and so
that's kind of where you get rama tut
becoming kane the conqueror
and the reason why he chose to become
that character we left that out in the
last video that we did because
honestly i felt like it would overly
complicate things
it was a complicated video already i
didn't want to make it even worse but
that's where these things all kind of
tie together and all sort of get
involved
now one of the big questions a lot of
people are going to ask is how does
limbo work in marvel comics okay so you
do have
a mortise's realm of limbo which is
considered true limbo and then you have
limbo which is basically ran by ileana
rasputin they're two distinctly
different places
originally we didn't know this but when
you go and you read the magic series one
through four back in 1983 or you go read
uncanny x-men 160 or you read avengers
forever issue number eight what it
establishes
is that the realm that magic basically
rules right that that kind of limbo
dimension
is more on more kind of defined by chris
claremont as being quote unquote on the
edge of hell
right that's why you have like demons
and stuff like that there where immortus
resides
is true limbo so it's basically a place
that's outside of time
and that's why when you look at
characters like king the conqueror or
rama tut
while they do have different variations
divergent versions of themselves with
immortus there's only one version of him
right and he literally just exists in
his chronopolis giant city
right in his castle called tenebre out
there in limbo now the important thing
about this
is that as time progressed specifically
when you get into uh avengers forever
issue number eight again kind of
explaining all this
that when ramatta basically decided to
become immortals right that version of
rama tut went on and fully became
the character of a mortise and agreed to
basically become an agent of the time
keepers
because the time keepers were always
working to ensure that the reality where
they reigned supreme instead of the time
twisters
came into fruition that this basically
led to immortus acting as a servant of
them
and what he was given was kind of like
this 70 century long
area to manage so imagine you've been
given like a giant piece of land
to till and to farm and to grow and make
sure that it grows crops as it's
supposed to and then imagine that on
like
the time stream and that's basically
what a mortise was given the bigger
purpose
that this really served as far as the
timekeepers were concerned
was to ensure that the timekeepers would
come into existence or at least their
future was maintained because it was
believed that somewhere between 3000 bc
and 4000 ad a person would rise to power
that would threaten the
the existence of the time keepers that
person of course ended up being the
scarlet witch
and that's the reason why between
fantastic four annual number two
avengers issue number 269
uh really going all the way up to
avengers west coast number 61
that immortus had basically been quote
unquote tasked with killing the scarlet
witch
now the important thing about this is
that immortus also had his own goals and
his own ambitions and so while the
timekeepers tasked him with killing the
scarlet witch
the reality was that as far as immortus
was concerned he could kill two birds
with one stone that not only could he
keep the scarlet witch from basically
preventing the time keepers from coming
into existence because
you know her hex abilities had to have
the power to alter the outcome of the
universe which is what made her a nexus
being in the first place but that he
could also
use that for his own ends and so what he
started doing was kind of operating
behind the scenes
and sort of nurturing the progression of
the scarlet witch's existence and so
when you go into avengers west coast
number 61 it was basically one of these
stories where marvel
essentially gave us the idea that
immortus was the reason why
scarlet witch and vision got together in
the first place now the reality is that
it was more the children of scarlet
witch that would cause all kinds of
different problems but the important
thing here is that immortus basically
saw a means by which he could prevent
the scarlet witch from having any kids
in the first place
and so when you go with avengers west
coast number 61 then you look at
avengers number 81
the whole idea is that if scarlet witch
had a kid with like a biological
guy then those kids would prove to be
insanely powerful and it would fulfill
the prophecy that the offspring of the
scarlet witch would basically destroy
the future
by which the timekeepers ruled
everything and so by getting her
together with vision of course scarlet
witch and vision can't have kids
vision is a robot so kind of organizing
that the hope was that scarlet witch
would never have any kids at all of
course we saw how that played off when
she basically ended up just taking the
shards of mephisto and making kids out
of them and then they were ultimately
taken away but the early days of
immortus
largely saw him facing off against the
avengers team right avengers issue
number 10 those various stories going
forward and a lot of that was because at
the time when marvel comics was writing
stories they would usually introduce new
villains
villains that could potentially have a
lot of impact on the marvel comics
universe and popular stories which made
sense right it wouldn't really make a
whole lot of sense to introduce somebody
like immortus in the pages of like
marvel two-in-one
or marvel premiere or marvel feature or
something along those lines and so by
featuring him
in the avengers and having like these
kind of time travel escapades
it was kind of interesting but the
initial real big explosion here the kind
of first thing that popped off
which really led into a mortise was a
conflict with a character by the name of
the space phantom now the space phantoms
are a little interesting because they
basically exist
in limbo with immortus they're really
more servants of a mortise he kind of
took the place over when he arrived
there and then they all started working
under him
along with uh tempus who he basically
controls but the origin of the space
phantoms is a little bit wonky
the long and short of this at least in
terms of how marvel kind of explains it
to us and then changes it all the time
is that space phantoms can largely be
believed that they are people who were
trapped in true limbo and then basically
forgot themselves but then when you go
back and you read other stories
it's that these space phantoms actually
came from some other location
and then arrived in limbo and had been
there for a long long time
maybe forgot who they were maybe
remember who they were but they couldn't
escape or just liked it there and chose
to stay there but regardless of the
motivation space phantom was introduced
as a villain of the avengers by immortus
because space phantom had the ability to
duplicate the bodies of others
all this came to a head when he faced
off against thor and then of course thor
was immune to his abilities and the
space phantom was defeated and that was
really immortal's first realization that
the avengers were a credible team
and so in the early days with stan lee
don heck a few other writers here and
there roy thomas and so on you basically
saw immortus facing off against the
avengers and then occasionally stepping
in properly working with characters like
the masters of evil trying to help
baron zemo defeat and destroy the
avengers different things along those
lines and that's something to keep in
mind here immortus was not
nearly as active as king the conqueror
was in terms of his goings on with
with regards to the various characters
who were there again avengers being the
main focus avengers 107 avengers 108.
these were stories where vision was a
little hesitant about having a
relationship with the scarlet witch and
so the idea was that immortus actually
sent space phantom to earth to
essentially
kind of give vision a bit of a
confidence boost when he had a space
phantom team up with grim reaper and
then kind of off revision a human body
potentially the other side of that story
the way it was
written was that the vision lacked
confidence uh much like what you saw in
the marvel cinematic universe he didn't
really see himself as somebody that
could actually have
a real meaningful relationship because
he wasn't human so he would seemingly
outlive
everybody and even then he lacked the
emotional components it was largely just
a story that focused on the vision as a
character it became
a really significant moment when you get
into the second volume of vision and
scarlet witch really more so than the
first by bill mantlow because that focus
on magneto being you know scarlet
witch's father but uh that focus
was huge when it came to the old school
avengers stories by roy thomas and then
later on in avengers west coast but kind
of
solidifying this idea that like you know
scarlet witch can't have kids now
a lot of that really began to change and
things in and immortus himself
really began to have a far more
prominent role by the time he got to
avengers 129 and giant size avengers
number two
and the reason for this and we talked
about this during the our video
explaining kang
was the celestial madonna and the whole
idea behind the celestial madonna for
those of you guys who never saw that
video is that it was a being who existed
in the the marvel comics universe
that if they ever had a child would
prove to be the most powerful being in
the entirety of the universe
of course we knew that person ended up
being mantis but the important thing is
that much like kane the conqueror and
rama tut that
immortus wanted to take the celestial
madonna for himself and then
procreate with her so that his child
would basically become the most powerful
being in existence and then of course he
would take that child away whisk them
off to the realm of limbo and then train
them for their own
ends and then of course most likely
conquer all the universe but that's why
he's a little bit wonky when it comes to
marvel because he's not really a bad guy
but he's not really a good guy he's kind
of like this in-between
thing right where his allegiance is more
so to ensuring that he that no other
version of kang
ends up you know ruling the end of time
except for himself but then
also serving his role as part of the
timekeepers because the whole bargain
that was made between him and the
timekeepers was
if you fail to prevent our timeline from
coming into existence we'll wipe you
from the time stream and then will
destroy everything on earth and
basically
allow humanity to start over or
something along those lines so it was
kind of wild and the reason why i say
this is because this is one of those
times when a mortise basically became a
good guy that at the end of the
celestial madonna story arc that because
kang was so close to capturing mantis
that immortus came to the realization
there really wasn't any hope for him to
succeed and the enemy of his enemy is
his friend and so he basically allied
himself with the avengers to essentially
ensure that kane could not succeed he
kind of went forward as a friend of the
avengers from there and a lot of his
stories
really just dealt with him just kind of
hopping and skipping through the time
stream
helping the avengers you know retrieve
somebody like hawkeye or something along
those lines
there wasn't a whole lot that was going
on there but there was
a massive moment with the character of
mortis
and anybody who knows anything about his
character knows exactly what we're
talking about
probably one of the weirdest and maybe
worst decisions
that marvel ever made so the whole idea
behind this was that jim shooter was
editor-in-chief of marvel at the time
and this guy made a lot of less than
stellar decisions he made some great
decisions like crafting the original
secret wars event but a lot of the
decisions that he made were not that
great and so what had happened was that
in avengers issue number 200
that immortus had in effect grown bored
with his time
in in limbo and the whole idea behind
this was to basically write him out
right to get rid of immortus as he
existed
and replace him with a younger more
vibrant version of himself
and so what ended up happening is he had
to kind of search the time stream
looking for a soulmate and found a woman
who was destined to die
after basically drowning on a ship he
whisked her away to limbo romanticized
her got her knocked up
and then ultimately she had a son named
marcus now eventually
she was removed from the equation and
then marcus existing inside limbo
was really like the sole occupant there
when a mortise had seemingly vanished
right again marvel with the intention of
writing him out
the reason why this is so important and
the reason why this is one of those
stories that people look at
like this is weird is because depending
on how you look at it people interpret
it different ways
some people interpret it as basically
marvel writing a story where
the body of uh carol danvers was
completely violated others see it as
just a weird story that marvel wrote
somewhere along the line but the
important thing is that marcus
sought to be reborn in the universe
seemingly with a with all of his powers
and everything intact
but he couldn't just leave the realm of
limbo it didn't work that way because if
he just left he would basically die so
what he ended up doing was whisking
carol danvers to the realm of limbo and
then tricked her slept with her
got her pregnant and then the idea was
that when she gave birth to her baby on
earth that she would give birth to
marcus so marcus would essentially give
birth to himself now at the time marvel
wrapped that story up with a quickness
and marcus basically went back to limbo
and then died of old age
so marvel got rid of that fast it was
nuts but it still lingers on
people don't forget marvel and so
following that and really for like
decades going forward
immortus would just kind of operate
behind the scenes largely serving the
purpose that was given to him by the
time keepers to essentially prune the
timeline
of realities that are not supposed to
exist or realities that are a threat to
the existence of the time keepers
themselves realities just never really
mattered and the stories were okay
and they were kind of interesting
because you'd see you know these
alternate reality depictions of
characters where like you know lee
harvey oswald never assassinated john f
kennedy and things along those lines
but the constant theme with immortus was
this obsession with the scarlet witch
because realizing that the hex powers of
the scarlet witch and her ability to
manipulate the time stream
is something the timekeepers were so
concerned of especially when it came to
her kids that immortus was always
looking to find a way
to basically ensnare the scarlet witch
and then use her for his own
ends initially a lot of this came during
the original or really during the second
vision scarlet woods story west coast
avengers some follow-up stories when her
and vision kind of gave birth to billy
and tommy when they used the shards of
mephisto
of course mephisto himself had sent
master pandemonium forward to kind of
get his shards back and so at that point
there wasn't really a lot of concern
from immortus because it was kind of
like okay
you know like these kids this is this is
a great huge thing everything's gonna
pop off and then the problem basically
seemed to solve itself with master
pandemonium
serving on behalf of mephisto took those
shards back and basically billy and
tommy were
you know by all standards of measurement
killed and then that kind of you know
had the the whole memory wiped from the
mind of scarlet witch by i get the
harness and all that kind of stuff so
there wasn't really a whole lot for a
mortise to do there you saw some events
some things going on
acts of vengeance for example when loki
gathered together all the various
villains are the most notable
villains of marvel and then switched
around what characters they were
fighting
in the hopes that it would lead to a
great big huge conflict and the villains
would reign supreme
and defeat all the different heroes so
think like old man logan before old man
logan but again the main focus was
always on the scarlet witch
now all this really came to a head when
you got to the events of what was really
avengers west coast number 62
and even going into stories like 61 and
so on and so forth but the whole thing
about this is that immortus had
basically made his move
to capture the scarlet witch along with
the rest of the avengers and bring her
to the realm of limbo for the purpose of
bestowing on her the ability to
seemingly manipulate time
and then use that in order to control
the entirety of the time stream which
would actually allow him to usurp the
authority of the time keepers themselves
the reality was that scarlet witch
rejected that she rejected all that
power and the timekeepers gave him
mortis what they what he wanted when
they bonded him with the ability to
manipulate the entire time stream now
the truth about this
is that marvel sought to just write
right and mortis out yet again right to
get rid of him by having the ability to
manipulate the whole of the time stream
but not being able to do anything with
the ability to manipulate the time
stream he was quite literally just
frozen just
just stuck there and there was nothing
he could do marvel wanted to write him
out and get rid of him in his entirety
and so that's why
between avengers west coast issue number
62
and marvel what if volume 2 issue number
35 for that two-year period you didn't
see
anything from immortus now eventually
marvel brought him back and when they
brought him back in a what if story it
was a little
interesting because normally what if
stories in marvel comics
never really deal with a crossing over
with the main marvel universe outside
of the purpose of the what if story
which is to say what if spider-man kept
the venom symbiote what if doctor
strange was
a student or disciple of dormammu that's
the only real
crossing over that you saw instead what
you saw here was a story that kicked off
called what if the watcher
saved the marvel universe say the
entirety of the universe and what you
ended up learning
is that the time keepers as they've been
depicted were not actually the time
keepers those individuals who had
basically led to the defeat of immortus
then instead what had happened
is the time keepers had been replaced
with the time twisters and the time
twisters had basically moved the
timekeepers out of the way
and by virtue of everything that had
gone on with west coast avengers had
actually
imprisoned immortus and the whole thing
was to get him out of the way so they
could kind of go through
and start conquering the timeline which
really brought in a lot of older stories
with the time twisters in terms of how
they were able to run awry
through different points in the time
stream and so ultimately you ended up
having the watcher who was kind of
manipulated to a degree from behind the
scenes
by immortus and then in turn immortus
made himself
really revealed his identity to the
avengers once he grabbed everybody
together
for the purpose of launching a kind of
final attack against the time twisters
and essentially saving all of existence
and so what the timekeepers freed and
then realizing what it was
immortus had done at the end of the day
they saw it as somewhat of an honorable
thing so they sent him back to limbo
they restored him back to his normal
form
and the whole purpose was to basically
prevent a point whereby the time keepers
would
cease to come into existence now with
the whole idea of the scarlet witch
having kids which would threaten the
reality of the time keepers since that
had kind of been nullified
during the uh during the whole story arc
with master pandemonium and all that
kind of stuff that the new threat that
would that had really come up was kind
of the return of an old threat which was
something called the destiny force now
the destiny force was this idea whereby
humanity would tap into its true
potential
and then basically conquer the universe
right humanity would be exceedingly
powerful
and so to prevent that from happening
that went into the avengers forever
story which basically saw that immortus
killed rick jones who was the original
possessor of the destiny force and would
basically spread it to the rest of
humanity of course that leads to the
whole avengers forever storyline and the
idea of cain the conqueror and rama tud
and nemouritas all having their origins
revealed and all that kind of stuff and
there were a few other stories
that came out around that time for
example you had the crossing that story
sucked
no one likes the crossing so we're not
even gonna worry about covering it here
but the big thing is that immortus was
just kind of a background character
right there wasn't
a whole lot going with him that almost
all the focus
on this alternate reality version of
nathaniel richards that would go on to
become rahmatut kane the conqueror
immortus that a lot of that emphasis
was put on king that was the big focus
of of really marvel comics at the time
and so what you ended up seeing were a
couple of things that went on which was
really largely
immortus trying to prevent king from
rising to power in that way
trying to prevent king from expanding
throughout the entirety of the time
stream
and keeping him from being a credible
threat or a person who really could
dominate and control the entirety of the
multiverse now one of the more
interesting examples of this came in
uncanny avengers for those of you guys
who are not familiar with uncanny
avengers this came in the aftermath of
avengers versus x-men right so those of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
story the whole idea of avengers versus
x-men is that the phoenix force was
basically coming back to earth
and the mutant population was
celebrating it because they believed it
would kind of lead to the return of a
messiah which would really come in the
form of hope summers
the other part of this is humanity was
terrified because they they were afraid
that something like the dark phoenix
saga would happen again
where whoever the phoenix force
possessed would go absolutely crazy
and possibly even destroy the world or
the whole universe and so what you ended
up getting was the great big huge
conflict between the avengers and the
x-men well in the aftermath of all that
captain america had the idea that they
all had kind of have to work together
and so you got what was in effect the
avengers unity squad which was basically
a team that was composed of one part
avengers and one part
x-men they ended up of course using the
name avengers because of the avengers
and they used uncanny because of how
long
and and prolific the uncanny x-men run
of chris claremont had been
regardless one of the big things that
had happened here was the actions of the
apocalypse twins and the apocalypse
twins were basically the offspring of
of of warren worthington archangel who
you might be familiar with uh and they
were taken by king the conqueror into
the future
so kane the conqueror could raise them
based on his own philosophies
and then bring them back to initiate
what they call the rapture of the mutant
population on earth and so
immortus sought to stop this from
happening because of the legitimate
threat that came the conqueror post
and so while you had the avengers teams
that formed and the various superhero
teams that got together to try to find a
way to stop
king you had immortus who was forming
something called the infinity
watch now the infinity watch has a very
lengthy group in marvel comics
in reality the affinity watch started
off as basically a group of individuals
that guarded the infinity stones
over the years this kind of changed in
this instance it was really more of just
a team
that was kind of called the infinity
watch because the in the infinite nature
of the time stream and it was basically
a team composed of different people from
different times throughout the time
stream itself but ultimately the efforts
of immortus the avengers all those guys
ended up failing and so what you got was
basically this alternate reality version
of kang
along with his uh his core that
basically showed up and then took the
minds of the avengers
back to their bodies in the present days
so they essentially have
all the memories of how everything
unfolded and then they'd be able to stop
it which they successfully did they
ultimately stopped the destruction of
earth that was done in one part by the
apocalypse twins and then also cleansed
by exotar the executioner and so with
that with that day kind of being saved
and mortise went back to his process of
just kind of monitoring and watching and
operating from behind the scenes
now following that there were a few
stories like when he appeared in
paradise x universe x it really was more
just paradise x and the possibility of
him becoming king things like that but
the truth of the matter is that marvel
just
met like a mortar's just gone right
marvel just stopped writing him one day
and the reason why
is because the death of a mortise had
actually happened in 1993
it happened in a story called the
terminatrix objective and the whole idea
behind this was
that immortus had basically married an
alternate reality version of ravana
rinslayer
and then in turn they adopted another
alternate reality version of ravana
and that version of kang their child
named marcus immortus or at least
renamed him to marcus amortis
and so like old people they quite
literally retired to limbo and then just
met their demise when they brought in
six versions of ravana and then had one
of them
destroy kang and his wife and then
following that they were dead right
they've just kind of been out of the
picture ever since and it's a weird way
to do things because normally when you
kill off a character it's just like you
know this event happens and then they're
dead
you don't normally stop writing a
character because somewhere along the
line they had already died but that's
the complicated nature of the character
of a mortise it's because they exist
throughout the time stream and different
things that happened to them
throughout the time stream that you
might see them in the year
2030 but they may have actually died 500
years prior they just haven't gone back
to the point when they die right and
that's why when you look at characters
like immortus you'll see him in what if
stories you'll see him in just
alternate reality stories like universe
x or paradise x or something like that
because he's a guy that functions
throughout the multiverse so there's
only one of him throughout the entirety
of the multiverse in the same capacity
that you would see
somebody like the living tribunal show
up in an alternate reality it's the
exact same living tribunal you've seen
up here in the main marvel universe it's
just
only one living tribunal throughout all
of creation immortus is the exact same
way there's only one immortus throughout
the entirety of the multiverse so no
matter what story you
see him in in marvel comics that's the
main marvel universe immortus right
there's only one of him so
again i know it's wonky it's a it's a
weird character it's one of the reasons
why i held off on explaining him for so
long
uh if we do explain another character
like another version of kang it's gonna
be a little while
because my brain is fried but thank you
guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace